the number of new infections in india's
omicron driven third wave appears to be
dropping cases have not been as severe
as the deadly second wave but it has
still taken a toll especially in large
cities
one of the critical components in the
country's health care system are
community women workers they go door to
door to check on people and help them
but these women at the front lines feel
they never got the recognition they
deserved and in new delhi thousands have
gone on strike this month here's dw's
report
these women are angry
for 11 days now they have been blocking
an arterial road in the heart of new
delhi
they are primary health or anganwadi
workers as they are known
during the last two years they have been
at the front line of the pandemic at the
grassroots level
they distributed masks promoted
vaccinations and raised awareness
they worked through lockdowns and
coronavirus waves without any protective
equipment for themselves
and earned as little as 60 euros a month
we weren't even given sanitizers we
arranged for masks gloves and sanitizers
on our own so that we could continue our
work
i've worked for 36 years in this job but
i am not entitled to a pension this is
why we are protesting for basic worker
rights we get no protection i've lost
three family members to coronavirus yet
i went to work with my toddler intro
because we were told we cannot take
leaves
thousands of workers here are demanding
better working conditions and more pay
punam rani has run an anganwadi center
for nine years
she says she is so overworked that she
doesn't have time for her own children
the government doesn't value women's
labor they think we will work a lot for
very little wages as women we end up
accepting these terms because we figure
at least we're earning something because
unemployment has skyrocketed under this
government
angadvaris were first set up decades ago
to fight child hunger and malnutrition
[Music]
women like rani helped monitor the
health of children and their mothers
and distribute food rations
with this immediate link to families
anganwadi workers like rani have close
access to the thousand people they each
have under their care
so over the years they have been charged
with looking after many additional
social benefits
and are now handling extra duties to
help out during the pandemic without any
added compensation despite their
increasing workload these workers are
only recognized as volunteers one of the
key demands of these protests is for
them to be given the designation of
permanent employees of the government
and to also receive the benefits that
come with that job
this would include health insurance
pensions and vacation costs which union
leaders here say the government is
reluctant to take on they say the
current system blatantly exploits
women's labor they are not producing a
tangible commodity but they are in a
service which is crucial which is
essential and without which even
governments can't function i believe
that government is trying to run away
from its principal responsibility
the delhi government is yet to respond
to these protests
these women are now planning to travel
through the country to call out what
they say are the false promises
political parties are making to workers
that report from dw's namisha jaiswal
and ahmad shariq let's bring in ndw's
delhi bureau chief amrita chima thanks
for joining us
so no response yet from the government
is there public support for these
community health care workers or are
they on their own
now there is considerable public support
for these workers you know they play
such a key role at the grassroots level
they have a deep reach in the community
and which is what makes them such a
valuable resource for the government in
times like this in times of a pandemic
they have connections they have deep
relationships in the community now this
the heart of the problem really melissa
is that these workers are viewed as
volunteers and not at as employees now
this is where the unions are fighting
the battle for these workers and say
these people should be treated as
employees and given all the protections
there are talks now going on between the
government and the unions trying to look
for some kind of a compromise and see
what they can come up with but the last
time these women got a hike was in 2017
and that was after 50 days of strike so
these women are very determined and
they're going to be sitting there quite
literally till they get what they want
got it now omicron infections are easing
in some parts of the country is there a
sense that india's healthcare system is
on top of the situation
well the healthcare system is in a much
better position than it was last year
during the deadly delta wave and there
are two reasons for this uh um melissa
one is that the hospitals and
authorities were much better prepared
than the last time and secondly the
omicron wave is very transmissible but
it didn't spread as fast as people
thought it would and also it's simply
not as deadly as the delta wave the last
year when the delta wave took india by
storm we saw horrific scenes if you
remember people gasping for dr
breath
and actually you know not having enough
oxygen so many people died not enough
hospital beds but this time things are
much better and as i said a combination
for the fact that people are better
prepared hospitals are better prepared
and they're facing a variant which is
not as ferocious as the last time
india faced the huge task of vaccinating
i mean more than a billion people
against covet i'm curious how that's
coming along
actually melissa pretty well after a
fairly slow start vaccination has really
picked up and the health minister
gave latest data on the number of people
vaccinated above the age of 18 those who
are eligible he said that 95 percent had
received the first dose and 76 had
received the second dose as well and he
also talked about teenagers people
between the ages of 15 and 18 and said
10 million of them had got birth doses
so india is doing pretty well in terms
of vaccination as you said over a
billion people to be vaccinated and to
get that number as high as that is quite
a a significant achievement i mean that
95 percent is better than germany and
now we've seen mass gatherings like
religious festivals and political
rallies drive new surges in the country
and i know we have a big regional
election getting underway in uttar
pradesh it's a state with 200 million
people i'm curious have there been steps
taken to control crowd sizes there
in fact uttar pradesh has a population
which is half the size of the european
union so elections which started there
today are going to go on for a month in
seven phases the election
commission gave guidelines as to how
these
rallies and campaigns could take place
but of course no one is paying any
attention the election commission said
not more than 50 capacity in indoor
auditoriums and not more than 30 percent
outdoors they said only 20 percent at
two so i beg your pardon only 20 people
were allowed to go for door-to-door
campaigns they put a bar on rallies
processions and so on but if you look at
the pictures you will see that no one's
paying any attention to these guidelines
many thousands and thousands of people
are out at these rallies there's no
social distancing hardly anyone is
wearing a mask not even the politicians
so we'll just have to wait and see
melissa what happens after these
elections are over in a month or so
because last time in a similar situation
when there were regional elections in
india we saw a huge spike in the number
of new infections
dw's delhi bureau chief amita chima
thank you for that roundup
[Music]
turning now to the challenge of long
covid which some now call the parallel
pandemic
estimates suggest more than a third of
covid survivors will develop symptoms
that linger long past the initial
infection they can range from headaches
to fatigue and also to more serious
conditions we take a closer look at this
from india where dw's menier chaudhry
reports
sadhna tandon calls her pet dog pepper
her lifeline
she says the pup keeps her on her toes
all day
something which she says was not
possible just a couple of months ago
63 year old sadhna was infected with the
coronavirus during the second wave while
her initial infection was not severe a
few days after testing negative she was
diagnosed with cardiac inflammation a
post covert complication which left her
with a crippling weakness for months i
used to feel so weak so weak that i
would at times used to feel like i can't
even sit i must lie down i hardly had
any stamina i was though a very active
person earlier
and i started feeling depressed also i
used to feel it very low sadhna's case
is not exceptional
many other people have suffered from
post covert complaints
more commonly known as long covet
a name given to the persistent illness a
person feels while facing symptoms or
effects for weeks or months after
testing negative for the coronavirus
dr ayush gupta says patients have come
to him with complications like headache
fatigue depression palpitations and
cardiac issues among others a staggering
number that is 60 to 70 percent of
patients who recover from covid
have these effects on them there are
some kind of risk factors which predict
long covet duration of illness is one
severity of illness is second it is not
completely understood it is a science in
evolution so even young patients may be
experiencing more symptoms than an
elderly high risk patient
30 year old roshni divakar was an avid
yoga practitioner
she says she was at her healthiest stage
when she tested positive during the
second wave and her infection was quite
mild
but soon after she started experiencing
complications and was diagnosed with a
balanced disorder called vestibular
disorder which makes her feel dizzy and
causes constant ringing in her ears it's
like being on a boat
all the time
so when i stand it the floor is like
this so for me to walk straight is a
struggle there was a point where i
literally needed to be lifted to go
anywhere because i just couldn't get my
balance it can be very overwhelming and
exhausting while for roshni it has been
rehabilitative therapy and yoga that
have helped her gain a sense of control
over her condition for sadhana it's been
medication ample rest and her pepper
which helped her with her post-covet
complication he sleeps with me he eats
with me like a small child i have a
grandchild home now
[Laughter]
sadhna says she is a lot better now as
she has found some happy distraction
with pepper
but for many like her the lingering
effect of kovid remains inexplicable